cliff it's lovely to see you here today
your movie the Dark Horse's of course
based on the true story of New Zealand
chess champ Genesis protein II and Jen
was a very imposing man physically but
he had this wonderful childlike warmth
tell me a little bit about bringing that
to the big screen why is the genesis of
such an incredible human being in terms
of his heart and of course physically he
was an imposing you know they said he
was like a freight train when he walked
into a situation or a room and so
physically he's so different from me but
but the real challenge underneath all of
the layers of that man was the cements
heart and the submitters ability to
connect with people and to make them
feel loved and and valued and so and
that was the real challenge for me to
sort of you know peel back the layers of
my scrawny little heart and so like pump
it up to sort of be able to embrace the
way that this man walked through life so
beautifully and majestically and so
selflessly constantly wanting to give
and to share his love of the game of
chess but most of all helping you know
those less fortunate to realize their
own potential and life and that's that's
kind of you know that's that's that's at
the heart of the movie and it's very
inspiring and it's only there's a very
rare opportunity that you can get a
vehicle that can that can maintain that
line truthfully and authentically and
not not so sentimentally or
manipulatively in any way just to really
be honest about like what it takes to be
that kind of person you talked about
being the most intimidating role that
you've taken on so far why is that oh
yeah well completely I mean physically
you know - 300 pounds guy you bipolar
homeless possibly alcoholic you know I
just you know that was firstly there was
just the superficial stuff but then when
I watch a documentary on the man I met
his family I met his wife her son the
other people portrayed in the movie
noble Kela and the Jedi and there's
there's this tenderness and this really
unique family of people that I was now
beholden to that I had
honor you know I couldn't just like
whilst through this role in anyway I
really had to take on the responsibility
because this is a legacy for these
people in this community and all of the
people that he touched and helped and
moved to feel feel like it was a very
important movie for those people and
story for those people and say you know
very intimidating you don't want to you
don't want to take that on lightly
Genesis has a wonderful line in the film
which his um burned down the school
which he takes a course in one the last
you've been the Chancellor nobody uses
it in a very specific way to do with the
you know going forward and being bold on
the chessboard you know but I wondered
how much maybe or how far that attitude
might apply to acting and you in your
own career as well well yeah the line
burned down the school is in the in the
film and he you know he was like saying
you know life can be frustrating life
can be impossible life can be an immense
challenge of which you know we often
feel like we can't cope with and so the
metaphor and the film is like you can
take those frustrations you can take
that energy and those challenges on the
board and it's a safe place where you
can really throw everything that you are
against this your opponent in a safe way
and if you use that energy it was be
treated as like a religion really and so
for metaphor for me and my own life and
my own work you know the role was very
much that I was like well okay I'm
probably never going to not had this
opportunity in 10 20 25 years about live
government 30 years of an acting career
so it's probably not going to come along
again in a hurry so I just threw
everything I had at it and you know
that's like yeah burn the school down
like don't leave anything you know don't
leave anything any possibility and just
I wanted to give it my best shot and
that was the agreement that I mean with
James Napier Robeson the writer director
you know and produce and we were a team
on this and we all agreed that it was an
exceptional story and he was an
exceptional man and we had
to make an exceptional movie now you
mentioned of course you're very busy
acting career over the years they're
only very busy at the moment I wondered
what it's like stepping into and filming
for something like a spin-off from The
Walking Dead which of course has got
this huge fan base for it yeah it's a
completely different world like working
on us and a tiny independent film like
this and then working on the juggernaut
like that it's like it is like having
this split personality you know where
you know this massive machine behind the
The Walking Dead franchise is like this
global kind of juggernaut you know and
they're completely unrelated you know
they started to be doing that and many
ways is quite satisfying you know that I
can that I've got the breath of
possibility of my career that I can sort
of you know be be involved in those two
different extremes of our industry and
that one can actually help the other you
know that that hopefully the attention
that we get from this new television
show can help shine the bottle light on
this tiny little Jim and Atlas Jim can
move people's lives and hopefully you
know that's that's the aspiration that's
how that's how we do what we do I mean
you filming at the moment I've done the
pilot we did that and I had a great time
with Robert Kirkman Dave Alpert you know
the creator and producers and galleon
heard the exec producer and we've got
you know we've got this great team with
like come with we've got Adam Adam and
Dave Dave Erickson you know the writer
and director and so we had this great
team we've got it we've got a young we
got a young British actor in there Frank
Frank Dillane very talented young man
very international cast witnessed
Australian actress and and I'm from New
Zealand and we make this the spirit
family and yeah
and Kim Dickens of course so yeah it's
quite surreal like to think that these
these two
parts of me who exist in one part if you
had to describe what people could expect
how do you scribe your character how do
you describe the kind of feel of it the
color visuals they have given me a very
strict sort of limitations what I could
say I'm not even allowed to say my name
yeah no I'm not even allowed to said no
man don't even know to say the name of
the show because these things you know
these things are still aversion and I'll
even sad to say that the location
because you know really really strict
people I don't get it
I don't understand why this is how this
is so what bets all about but I've been
told and very clearly that I have to I'm
a lockdown yeah you know I've you I'd be
very happy to tell you what we've been
doing but what can we expect I think in
some ways they want to raise the bar in
terms of the if they can possibly I
don't know in terms of the relationship
stakes and the humanity they want to
they want to bring more humanity to the
characters and the relationships then
then the original franchise whatever
their means would you like to see it the
kind of worlds at some point maybe
crossover collide in some way I've not
seen the original series I don't know
I've not had your television for 25
years Wow
so I don't watch TV I don't watch a lot
of the stuff I do I'm quite happy it
doesn't go home and just take out the
trash you know look after the kids
well I'm sure garden I'm sure it's gonna
be a huge success and I really hope that
so the Dark Horse has all of the success
it deserves as well because it is such a
beautiful film and you play that part so
wonderfully thanks for talking to me
today clay thank you
you